[Music]
hey
here we are again yeah what [ __ ] day is
it tuesday
yeah we saw a [ __ ] up movie the other
day
[Laughter]
yeah i didn't really like it at first it
got better as it went though
this was an interesting movie now this
is this came out it's called anna and
the apocalypse uh we saw it on hulu but
i think
it might be on either shutter or uh
to be i think i saw it on another
platform but we just watched it on hulu
now this came out back in 2017 and i
guess
i am a stupid person because i didn't
really read
the synopsis all i saw was christmas and
zombies and i was kind of like oh okay
and then i'm like 10 minutes into it
somebody starts singing and i'm like oh
[ __ ]
it's a musical it's a british it was a
british
zombie music it's a zombie musical
yeah which i'm amazed nobody has done
that well
okay so the history behind this because
i looked it up a little bit
um i guess that this guy named ryan
mchenry who has since
passed away he actually passed away
before this movie came out there's like
a memorial tim at the end
he um had made this short film called
zombie musical
back in 2010 and i guess it won a bafta
so this is kind of like an extended
version of that
okay if you want the vibe of this movie
it's set in scotland
it's basically like glee meets
shawn of the dead it's kind of like that
but not quite as funny
but you know what i mean so but the
songs are good
and there's a little bit of because you
said it kind of reminded you a little
bit of rocky horror picture show
oh what's the matter a little bit once
the like with the song with the bad guy
and everything yeah
i tell you the truth the first like
20 minutes of the movie kind of felt
very stale and corporate to me
um it seemed like high school musical or
something but i guess that's kind of
what they were parodying i think they
were trying to
feel stale and corporate and kind of
like
soulless characters it did get better as
it went
but i guess that was kind of like the
tone they were trying to be like every
other
high school movie or something from 2017
which
to me a lot of this [ __ ] just feels
[ __ ] stale and corporate
but like i said i'm not really sure it's
hard to tell if that's correct
it's kind of what they were they were
parodying as well
because i think there was i mean there's
a scene you know part way through where
like the
the protagonist like the main i mean
it's it's kind of an ensemble cast but
like the main girl
anna she kind of comes out of her house
with her headphones on she's like
dancing down the street singing doing a
number and everything and like in the
background like all this horrifying [ __ ]
is happening like zombies are falling
out of windows and
cars are crashing and there's like smoke
and everything like that so i kind of
feel like
it was a very sean of the dead moment
like where he's just kind of walking
down the street not paying attention and
there's all these zombies wandering
around in the background
so i kind of got that that feel to it so
i feel like that's kind of why the first
you know 10 15 minutes of the movie were
set up almost like high school musical
or glee or something like that where it
was just like a very
corporate but like i will say though
that the i do like the songs the songs
were actually very catchy
yeah especially towards after you got
past like the first couple of i think
yeah and the first one i was just like
yeah well
i don't know just kind of a mixed bag
for me it wasn't a bad movie
it's just like i said mindset has a lot
to do with it i guess we
wasn't in the right mindset for it and i
wasn't like i said i was cause
all i was doing i'm looking for
christmas horror movies and i was just
big you know that came out in the last
few years because that's what we're
doing like for the next couple weeks
we're just doing christmas horror movies
this is i don't know if i would call it
a horror movie even though it is
you know as it goes on like when the
zombies start coming there is like a lot
of funny
gore gags in it like people getting
their head heads knocked off and
you know squished and blood spraying
everywhere and [ __ ] like that so it is
gory so it does have horror in that
sense but it's much more a comedy
and a musical than a horror movie and it
saw
it's it's set around christmas time but
it's not real
it doesn't hit christmas real hard
there's like there's a zombie at the
beginning that's in like a snowman suit
that at one point you know she's using
like a candy cane with a spike on the
end like a big plastic one like to stab
people with and like they go through
like a christmas tree lot and [ __ ] like
that
but it's not real i mean there's
christmas decorations and [ __ ] going on
in the background but it's not like
super super christmas
you know centered i guess you know what
i'm saying
um but that said i i can't decide like i
liked it
but i wish the only thing i wish is i
wish it was funnier
i just i wish it was a little bit
funnier because i feel like
well now there was some funny [ __ ] in it
like some of the [ __ ] that some of the
characters said and some of the
gore gags and stuff especially um kind
of made me like laugh
out loud there were so there were some
like really funny moments in it but i
i kind of got the sense that it was
trying to be sean of the dead except
with songs and it's not as funny as
shawn of the dead you know what i'm
saying
yeah but it was a similar vibe though so
if you like shawn of the dead you might
want to check this out but just keep in
mind and like i said i don't know
if some of my ambivalence at least until
it got like to the halfway point all the
zombies started showing up and it
started getting good
i don't know if my ambivalence was
because i didn't i wasn't expecting it
to be a musical
you know what i'm saying because i
didn't i didn't know that it was a
musical
until the girls like looked at the
camera and started singing and i was
like oh it's a musical
everybody's in here louie's in here
badgers in here
sophie's in here louie says hey tom
is it at least a movie yes
it's a movie i guess a lot of people
seem to dig this though because when i
looked at the um
the reviews like i saw the review that
bloodbath and beyond did when it came
out
and uh they really dug it and a lot of
people in the comments were like yeah
man i'm like obsessed with this movie
and a lot of people have the soundtrack
and everything like that
like i said yeah the songs are really
good in it and especially i think my
favorite song
in it was the bad guy who was like the
headmaster of this school
name i think his name is mr savage they
just called savage and i think his song
is just because he's just like so over
the top evil and he just like [ __ ]
leans into it kind of like something out
of rocky horror or phantom of the
paradise
or something like that phantom paradise
is better no i know that but i'm just
saying that
that's kind of that's what you said when
you were watching it that yeah
the paradise is a good musical that i
didn't know even know about she showed
it to me i was like oh yeah yeah
yeah we did a review of that a while
back yeah i like that one that movie is
crazy
but i was like yeah i'm like actually
surprised that
that this like doesn't this genre
doesn't have more entries in it i can't
really think of another zombie i'm sure
there's other zombie musicals right i'm
sure there's gotta be
but yeah i like like i said just if if
you're expecting it to be a musical you
will probably enjoy it more i just
wasn't
expecting it to be a musical so it was
like i was like oh okay this is what
we're doing now
but then like like you said like after
the zombies showed up i was kind of like
oh okay
now i'm on board um because a lot of the
gore gags were really funny and there
was still music in it after that
but and but some of the songs were fun
it got more fun like after the zombies
showed up because i feel like the first
part of it was just kind of like a glee
episode and then suddenly there were
zombies and then it got better
um and you know like i said i would have
liked a little bit more christmas a
little bit
funnier like i said it had some humor
like a lot of humor in it but
some of the humor was just kind of like
you know what i mean but some of it was
like laugh out loud funny but it wasn't
nearly as funny as shawn of the dead
waiting for zach to show up in the
comments he should should have shown up
because just a few minutes ago he was
sharing [ __ ] profile pictures
to me she's sending me these his [ __ ]
grinder hookups
[ __ ] you know this one's
spooky-looking
i don't know why he's gonna show me he
wants me to [ __ ]
you're like you're like the dad you guys
i gotta approve
his grinder hook it's like does this one
look like a serial killer
what the [ __ ] is yeah what is that
david june says check seek my approval
about what man he's gonna [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
his eye he's spooky man that [ __ ]
show me this [ __ ] man that one picture
you just showed me this
was kind of that was kind of he he
wasn't ugly he was just kind of strange
looking he's like a human hornet
is
the new superhero from marvel comics
you've been hornet
but uh yeah david june says check out
holidays uh on netflix yeah that is a
good one i've seen that one that's
because that one that one doesn't have
just christmas that one
is like short films it's like an
anthology that's a whole bunch of
different
holidays like i think there's an easter
one in there and there's a st patrick's
day one and
[ __ ] like that i can't remember all the
ones that are in there but i remember
what i think i watched that last year or
the year before and i remember liking
that one a lot
yeah so yeah that is another one on
netflix i don't know if we're gonna
we might review it at some point but i
don't know if it's necessarily
around the christmas time because it
doesn't have just christmas it has like
all different holidays like i think oh
it has a valentine's one day day one two
i think i remember
yeah but uh yeah so that was really good
um so
what else oh oh oh um so tomorrow i
because i have a
christmas horror movie lined up that i'm
gonna watch later that i'll probably
review tomorrow
now i might be doing the stream by
myself tomorrow but i'm not sure yet
because yeah i gotta go to the i gotta
go to the va he's gonna go to the va
tomorrow
and i've got my eyes checked every year
six months it's eye doctor yeah um
so and i'm not sure what time because i
think your appointment's at 12 30 right
so i
may be back by three you will probably
be back by three but i'm not really sure
if you will be um if you're not back by
three i'll just go ahead and do it
without you
um but if not i can send you a message
on the way tell you i'm being i'm
being late let me delay it a little bit
and then i can delete it yeah yeah yeah
that'll work so yeah so i'm just saying
if you know if it's going to be like a
long time and
you know i'll just go ahead and do it by
myself or i should be back in time
i would think they're just going to put
those eye drops in there and [ __ ]
expand them out and [ __ ]
it checked me for glaucoma every six
months
yeah yeah yes it's in my family and i do
have like in the back of my eyes
there's little things back there that
looks like they thought it
they thought for a while that it looked
like i might develop glaucoma but it
never got any worse so
well that's why they keep checking it
could just be genetic
yeah you know so i i don't think it'll
hopefully it'll never turn into it but
my dad he
he got glaucoma yeah they keep it under
control they put valves in there and
stuff to blow
pressure out that's crazy it's crazy
what they can do nowadays
right yeah and it's just they don't even
use any [ __ ] anesthetic they just
they just use here let me blow in your
eyeballs and just pop a damn
valve a pressure valve into the white
part of your eyeball
ridiculous really yeah i didn't know
they did that yeah so
if the pressure gets too high in there
it'll release the fluid from your
eyeball out to keep to
equalize the pressure because that's
what's happening in a glaucoma yeah
the pressure's building up and they're
too high yeah
that [ __ ] up [ __ ] up your peripheral
vision oh my god your peripheral vision
over the years gets worse and worse and
worse until you're
it's like you're looking through little
tubes yeah and
they've been checking it for years and
they haven't noticed any kind of decline
in my peripheral vision yeah because i
think you said
something it's been like several years
since you went and they
first said oh you you have like first
signs of that so we need to keep
checking but it's been like a really
long time
might have it but i probably wouldn't
live long enough for it to be in effect
anyway
yeah if it was it's moving so slowly but
they're not noticing it right
they're just keeping an eye on it make
sure it's not getting accelerating you
know
that's another thing kids when you get
old i until
maybe three years ago i want to say i
had
perfect vision you hit 40 and it goes in
like a couple
but well for me it was like yeah for me
it was like um
i got into you know my probably my early
mid 40s
and i had perfect vision i mean he would
like ask me hey can you read this tiny
little text
hey can you thread this needle can you
and i had no problem
and then like maybe over like a six
month period
just and then i just had to get reading
glasses then i'd get stronger reading
glasses
and now i can still see like f like far
away
but if i take my reading glasses off
this is all just a big blur
and that happened like that yeah
man agents [ __ ] [ __ ] up i'm 51 now
i'm [ __ ] holding together pretty good
but
that's not that impressive because
usually what happens is is that you
[ __ ] hold together real well till you
hit about 60
and then it was like a five year period
everything starts falling off
rapidly all your limbs start falling off
you you rapidly make the transition
right into [ __ ] old man happens right
after 60 between 60 and 65.
unless you're [ __ ] doing some
impressive [ __ ] with your metabolism
working out seems to help hormones
therapies seem to help
just to soften that [ __ ] blow you're
always going to age
but you can take the edge off of it and
i feel like maybe
um you know to a small extent i think
maybe your outlook might help too just
like don't
stress don't get into yeah one don't get
stressed out two
don't get into the mindset of being like
a cranky old person you know what i mean
that's hard for me to do it he is a
cranky old person already
yeah i get mad over [ __ ] but the thing
is is that
and i i can attest to this physical
stress
of [ __ ] physically working hard
weightlifting especially you know for
men
and things like that [ __ ] you know
hiking you know anything that's
stressful on you is good because it
keeps your metabolism
rolling it keeps your mentality uh
moving forward like you're growing
you're going through a growth thing
it's whenever when i look back at the
[ __ ] older generations you know like
my dad and all his friends
the ones that became sedentary and sat
around they rapidly died
they rapidly aged and died and i kind of
feel like something that
was very prevalent in that generation
too like i'm talking about like our
grandparents generation and some
somewhat our parents generation is that
i've
particularly the men i feel like they
their identities were so
wrapped up in their job yeah that a lot
of them died like they would retire and
then like a couple of years later they
croaked yeah they retired at 45 and they
were dead by 50 a lot of them
i mean my my grandfather retired i don't
remember what age he was
when he retired i think he was 65 and
then he
lived he only lived maybe another three
or four years i think
it wasn't that long yeah he i mean he
had like he smoked too like for
decades i think my grandparents
generation they were supposed to retire
around 55
something like this things when they
were supposed to retire yeah and i take
like a private business that
like run a shop but they didn't really
live that little much longer after that
anyway who knows what kind of poisons
they were
ingesting i mean you know a lot of the
[ __ ] the stuff that they sealed cans
with had lead
inside of tin yeah not the good old days
like and they didn't
know any of that stuff either yeah they
were around all kinds of toxic stuff
that even though it was poisonous yeah
they're just like whatever
yeah just makes you stronger put your
hair on your chest they smoked a lot
well yeah my grandfather did a lot a lot
of filterless cigarettes too
yeah yeah he smoked from when he was a
kid yeah um
but uh i tell you what man some of these
young guys
that i'm seeing coming up right now the
guys are in their 20s and 30s
i'm looking at them and i go those
[ __ ] are gonna fall apart like
my grandmother my
grandmothers and grandfather's
generation because they're sedentary
they're sitting behind
computer screens playing video games or
working behind computers
you've got to get out you got to [ __ ]
run do physical labor
if not you just start to atrophy
especially men
i think men take it harder than women a
woman can sit around a long time
a man can't they when they do that they
[ __ ] they die
heart heart problems circulation
circulatory problems
i think it has to do with the fact that
they it affects
male hormones i think testosterone
production
uh starts to uh subside
when you're not physically uh active
and uh you end up with all kinds of
weird like [ __ ] blood pressure
problems and
[ __ ] that it does to your arteries and
you just
you know i men i think are programmed
for an early death anyway
you know what i mean yes and i don't i
think males of most
most of the species are not we're not
really intended
to live that long because they had a
limited
use you know what i mean they would just
impregnate women and
catch [ __ ] and feed things and that's it
i don't think they were designed to live
very long
whenever you find like some of these
anxious skeletons you know
going back in 150 000 years the they're
the dead they're not they're not real
old but the
evidently the average age of the females
that seems to be older
you know yeah i think what ended up
happening back then because i think
people have a misconception that
people even up until the middle ages or
the industrial revolution or
that they died at 30 but that's not the
case it's just people
lived you know into their 70s 80s just
like nowadays it's just that the uh
averages got skewed because so many
peops so many kids died in
in childhood that too
but i think the men got hurt more often
well yeah that's true i mean back in the
day signs of broken bones and [ __ ] yeah
back in the day they were out like
hunting mammoths and [ __ ] like that
trying to grab animals and hold them
down you know you know falling off of
cliffs and getting stepped on and
getting jumped on by
tigers and all kind of [ __ ] like that
yeah all kind of dangers you don't have
to worry about anymore
well you know some we don't have to
worry about it like the women i think an
older woman
i think women could live into old age
more more reliably
back in the olden days yeah because they
were they were good for something they
could they could
watch children and you know help it back
at the camp
but old men there wasn't much they could
do maybe become like a damn
fortune teller or a [ __ ] priest or
you know magi
type guy and you know there wasn't going
to be like a whole bunch of job openings
for that he only needed a couple of
those in a big old tribe you know
practice the only couple of a couple of
60 year old dudes that survived
yeah they're like wow he must be wow
either that or he was smart enough to
stay in the cave and not go out hunting
after [ __ ] saber-toothed tigers
louis said our generation is going to
have to work until like 75 probably i've
already kind of come to terms with the
fact that i'm probably just gonna have
to work until i'm dead we work until
probably i'm not happy about it but it's
not like there's anything i can do about
it
tammy also said you have to keep your
mind active also my gram did taxes into
her 90s
she is now 101. yeah i definitely think
that that
is a large component of it learning new
stuff
just don't let yourself get ossified
yeah you know what i mean
like a lot of people are making
physically or mentally even even
kanavatsan you know he lives in tj
down in tijuana he worked he works for a
certain company and now
that company's made the transition of
everybody working at home like what me
and jenny do
and that's the future
a lot of people are slowly going to
transfer into online economies
the companies save a lot of money when
they don't have to rent
office space and it's not like the 1950s
where you have to have
well bob walking around with a damn
[ __ ] mug of coffee to making sure
everybody's doing their work
nobody's not doing his work from fire
him and hire another person you know i
mean just
you don't need supervisors like they
used to i certainly don't
yeah well you see office spaces man
office space that was a good one man
that's exactly that culture
[ __ ] way it was in boston [ __ ]
working for some of those corporations
that i work for [ __ ] that
and all that [ __ ] got [ __ ] outsourced
to other countries
but it was kind of justified because
they were kind of fake jobs anyway
they didn't do anything it was paper
pushing and
stup filling out tps reports it was it
was the way if
people back in the 1950s thought
companies had to run
yeah you know and that's not the way it
has to i mean honestly ever since i was
younger like when i was first getting
into the workforce back in the [ __ ]
90s
well i mean i wanted to work at home
yeah so i know people are complaining
about it and for some
people i understand that it's harder
particularly if you have kids because
you're always going to have kids
underfoot and you can't work
like you can't do zoom calls and your
kids are out there like pulling on your
hair and [ __ ] like
that i get that um but it's it makes so
much more sense
it does make so it's a lot more
efficient you can i i feel like i get so
much more done
you get a lot more done you're not
[ __ ] up your car i'm commuting to
yeah because i hate hate commuting
especially in orlando
and when you do that you're burning up
useless [ __ ] gasoline you're putting
all those useless miles on your car
and then the company's wasting all this
money they could be paying you a higher
salary instead they're gonna [ __ ]
pay mortgage on this brick and mortar
[ __ ] facility you're not getting any
of that money
it's just it's just not in your
advantage which
really you guys have been listening to
the show
following the show regularly since this
whole [ __ ] pandemic started
i told you how this [ __ ] was gonna go it
pretty much went that way
i'm not one of these [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] you know
green economy [ __ ] i don't
really have a lot of
i don't really have a lot of faith in in
any of that [ __ ]
the great reset thing to me sounds a lot
like the great leap forward i'm paranoid
of that
but you can see kind of what they're
talking about it
commuting to and from work and building
those big buildings is a waste of
[ __ ] time and energy
yeah it's a waste of resources it's a
waste of resources when you start
looking at it that way you also start
going
well you know what a downtown area is
nothing but those
offices and all kinds of facilities like
banks and [ __ ] like that
you really don't need that city sitting
there either
and i guarantee you people over the next
few decades those cities are going to
slowly become
kind of vacant and abandoned because why
do you need to live in one
you don't need to live in one because
the jobs aren't there anymore
where you are where your physical
location is has nothing to do with what
your job is
you could you could live right here in
this house and work on wall street in
new york you don't have to be in new
york
yeah i mean depending on what the job is
most most jobs like that
they're not there actually information
technology type of jobs you
wouldn't do you don't need to fees like
physically the rest of those jobs around
there are maintaining that city but
they're maintaining that city because of
those office spaces
and those office spaces are there
maintained in those apartment buildings
and those apartment buildings are there
because of that office space that
[ __ ] ecosystem is out is obsolete
which is kind of scary when you think
about it because that's an entire
way of life vanishing but
that's technological progress well yeah
i mean it feels like that's happened
before so
eventually everything yeah like they
don't build great pyramids anymore
they do that a couple times [ __ ]
there's
three big ones and then a bunch of
little ones because
why build a [ __ ] gigantic stone
resurrection machine
where you can just put it on paper and
call it a bible and carry it around it
does the same thing you go to heaven
yeah [ __ ] the breakfast right there just
put it right here
just write write about it as portable
resurrection machine
so you don't need that it's the same
thing so
but here's the deal you go okay so the
world's going to
[ __ ] slowly become kind of suburban
you know
can you move those urban populations out
into suburbia or does it overwhelm
the suburban areas and how can that
handle the population overflow
and then how does this affect things
politically certain political groups
depend upon an urban population as
they're for their voting
uh a [ __ ] uh uh population
does that mean pop does that mean
politics now has to change
because you don't have [ __ ] urban
populations anymore
so you know they not they now all start
having
rural and suburban consent concerns
instead of urban concern
this this [ __ ] here it's a trip
when i saw those movie theaters closed
down when i saw emc
start to falter and close down to me
jenny didn't like it to me i kind of
liked it i was like yeah we're finally
getting rid
of some old-fashioned [ __ ] it's been
around a long time yeah i like the
environment but
i could just do this from home but now
i'm kind of missing them theaters and
see
but that's never coming back that's
never coming back i saw the analysis
it's it's another inefficient way of
showing
you an intangible product to sell you an
experience that really isn't worth what
people are willing to pay for maybe live
theater will make a comeback
yeah i mean i know live theater never
really went anywhere but i mean
maybe it'll be like a big thing again i
don't know i'm just yeah
i'm just
and certain shit's changed no things
haven't changed like you know
you can go back decades or 100 years and
read about what they were worried about
in their newspapers they were worried
about railroads and
monopolies you know [ __ ] telephone
monopolies taking over the world and
running everything
never really happened those monopolies
are all gone well see that's kind of
what i always think about because
you go back and like look like when tv
started making you get worried about
in roads into like people's homes and
everybody was freaking out about that
and i'm just kind of like yeah that
didn't really
so it's like it's all right what's
affecting us is
just calm down it's like big tech is
kind of a monopoly right now and they
don't like you saying certain things on
your youtube shows they'll shut your
channel down
which i i don't agree with that at all
but then
it makes you wonder how long does will
big tech have that monopoly that they
have that's what i mean nothing is
forever
happens forever change i mean change is
is the only constant
right and that's what like i'm all right
with it it's like sometimes things
change and it sucks but then sometimes
things change it matters you don't
you can't you can't know like one person
can't know like how like how
shit's gonna shake out like in the
future so i just like feel like not
gonna worry about it
yeah because it always has like good
[ __ ] and bad [ __ ] just like everything
else
yeah [ __ ] um saying what's up i was
telling you
i was telling them about how we're all
working from home now the great reset
look at how that affects everything but
you know it's logical
it's so much better than commuting and
burning up all your gasoline
and putting [ __ ] miles and that's a
bunch of wasted
[ __ ] time yeah you're in traffic
going what the [ __ ]
that's what i used to think that every
day because i used to commute to a place
that was like
i mean it's not that far in terms of
miles but because i had to drive on i-4
which is like a huge [ __ ] parking lot
at pretty much every time of the day um
it would take me an hour and a half
to get there and an hour and a half to
get home and i was like that's
three hours out of my day when i'm stuck
in traffic
and i can't really do anything so it's
just like a huge
waste yeah i wasn't getting paid for
that time right
i wasn't getting anything accomplished
during that time i was just sitting
there
on the [ __ ] freeway
gasoline that you paid nearly three
dollars a gallon for right it's like so
it's just so i'm so happy
that that's all [ __ ] no tax deduction
on the gasoline well it may be on
certain states i think you could to
deduct that couldn't ya it's a bit yeah
it depends you can
um but it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you have to also understand that
that entire ecosystem of a [ __ ] city
is in jeopardy of [ __ ] collapse in
dell it probably
won't collapse quickly it'll collapse
slowly but
i think that might be the end of really
big cities because why do you need them
you know you just don't need them you
don't need them to work you don't need
them to go to work anymore
there will be some min there'll be some
people in the downtown area there's
certain things that will have to be
there
yeah but it won't be office work
it will yeah it won't be like work
related no
which uh that's mind-blowing that's some
futuristic [ __ ] so what do you do do you
knock down all those empty buildings
and here there are whole cities that
have vanished gary's gone
[ __ ] most of detroit is gone and i
think that's what will happen to some of
these big cities
is that they won't be you won't want to
live there and you won't want to work
there they'll just be empty buildings
and as well you know this is a [ __ ]
hazard knock that [ __ ] down
so i think some of that [ __ ] it'll be
like detroit detroit's a fraction of the
size of what it used
to be it still has a downtown area but
the neighborhoods are all gone
and a lot of the factories are all gone
all torn down
so what would new york look like in 50
years
will that be a small town a really good
downtown area
that looks like [ __ ] greek buildings
that were made in the 1800s
all the modern [ __ ] gone because you
don't need office abilities what happens
i don't know i guess we'll find out yeah
well i guess we probably won't because
that would be dead by then
but unless they give us cyborg bodies
but you know i lived in
i lived in detroit and i'll sign up for
that i lived in detroit in the late 80s
for
about a year and and outside of it in
trenton michigan for i think about
another year and half two years
and just within that period of time
no it's from that period of time till it
was just it was collapsing in those days
but if i look at it on google earth now
it's all gone
everything that i remember pretty much
about it is gone not there empty fields
yeah it's a trip well like i said it is
but it's like i guess i'm not
you know i've said this before i'm not a
super nostalgic person yeah
so i'm just kind of like well [ __ ]
happens we go like what happened to all
those ancient cities like troy
and [ __ ] well that's what happened to
them right there they just tore them
down and used them to make something
else
uh [ __ ] they became empty fields
slowly collapsed
like a flan in a cupboard got away yeah
so hopefully somebody got that reference
but we'll see
that well i know you did it somebody had
somebody in the comments probably
all right so uh you you had said
anything you wanted
everything you wanted to say yeah oh i i
meant to like tell the funny pookie
story that she came in here this morning
i wish i had got this on v i got the
video camera out and i started a taper
but then by the time i taped her like
she was or videotaped her she was
already
done yeah she tried to get underneath
the monitor of my big
and she can't really fit under there
anymore like she sort of can but she has
to like
get way down on her stomach and like you
know squish herself like in and i don't
know why she wants to do that
but so she gets in there and there's
like a notebook there
and so that was making it even harder to
get in and she was like squeezing her
little butt's like sticking out she's
like
and then she pushed herself under and
then as soon as she got under there she
turned around
all i saw was her little face come out
with her big eyes like she says the big
pupils were really big and black
and then her little claws came out and
then she pulled my notebook under there
with her
and started to eat the paper yeah louis
hernandez says
louie hernandez says he's in week two of
three weeks locked down
only that the elected officials don't
seem to need to follow the rules
yeah yeah everybody notices that man
you're not the only ones
you're not the only one that's noticing
that a lot of shit's coming to light
uh the next few years man is gonna be
a [ __ ] trip you know i just hope
i was telling jenny earlier i i hope
they don't just
start [ __ ] this thing where they
think well you know we can make a lot of
money selling these vaccines
you know if we came out with a more
deadly strain every two or three years
we can kill off all these uh old people
and all these like unwanted office
workers and we make a [ __ ] ton of money
let's just come out with a [ __ ]
tougher you know a worse strain of that
depopulate all these people i hope
it's not that i don't think they can get
away with that but there's no talent man
when
like i said there's a lot of [ __ ]
monopolies and [ __ ] big tech monopolies
that are doing [ __ ] i don't think that
[ __ ] is working though
even if some of the [ __ ] that they're
doing i think is a scam but i think a
lot of people see through it
i don't think it'll work forever the old
scams of the past
people rapidly caught onto them and
adapted to them
and the game changed so
it's it it's a [ __ ] weird time
but i don't think it's it's it a lot of
shit's gonna change but i don't think
it's anything we can't handle that's
what i'm thinking that's what i keep
saying it's gonna be okay
like even even if it's not okay in a
little while it'll be okay
and you'll just get through you'll just
deal with it every time we'll deal with
it everybody
will deal it yeah in a way it's like
it's sucky but
i know this is like a [ __ ] up thing to
say a little bit but it's like it's
almost better that like everybody's
going through it at the same time
you see what it is because well because
you don't feel
like because i think one of the worst
things about bad [ __ ] happening just to
you
is that you're alone and you don't
really have anything but when bad shit's
happening to everybody i'm not saying
that's great
but i'm just saying at least you have
other people to commiserate that no
because everybody's going through the
same [ __ ] you know what i mean so i so i
think that's kind of like a little bit
of a
silver lining i guess that's like
something that i thought of yeah i don't
think it'll ever get as bad as it was
in say like uh the early 1900s and when
you have
[ __ ] an empire like russia where
they're just [ __ ] wiping out
millions in their own population and
send them to siberia
has forced labor to [ __ ] dig channels
and
whole cities [ __ ] being starved out
you know
because uh because they were allowed
themselves to fall to the germans
you know there's nothing i don't think
there's anything like that ever gonna
happen that's what i mean it's like if
you look back in history like it was so
much [ __ ] worse
back then so it's like i feel like i'm
not saying that people nowadays don't
have any right to [ __ ] i'm just saying
that
i don't think it's gonna be that so bad
some of the [ __ ] that was doing during
this the era of [ __ ] joseph stalin
you know looking tens of millions of
people dying
i don't think it's ever gonna be like
that again it's just gonna be a bunch of
inconveniences and a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah like i said but that's what life is
all about yeah
life is inconveniences and [ __ ]
that's another t-shirt
inconveniences [ __ ] injustices
unfairness uh lies uh it's gonna be just
[ __ ] like that like i said so it was the
same [ __ ] different day
it's pretty much not gonna be i don't
think i don't think you're really gonna
have situations where mass starvations
and uh not fear anymore it's not here
i mean i'm not saying that might not
happen that might happen in certain
countries but i
i that would be countries that were
didn't have much of an infrastructure
anyway
you know stuff or you know
i don't know it's hard to say yeah it's
hard to say we're in the modern world
now it's hard
we're supposedly in a modern world every
everybody thinks they're in the modern
world throughout history
they thought well you are in the mind
you're in the modern world yeah you know
what i mean right you thought they were
back in ancient egypt isn't that funny
to think about it yeah they're like ooh
it's so modern nowadays
it's modern although it's well that's
what cracks me up like reading a lot of
the ancient greeks like socrates and
plato and stuff like that
they were bitching about generations
before them like how shitty they were
like ah these kids today with
this and they're that since they were i
mean you know what i mean like
ever since for thousands of years so
it's like it's nothing new
like complaining about old millennials
they were doing that
thousands and thousands of years ago
they were talking about kids words
were more [ __ ] up than their
generation our generation was so much
cooler and blah blah they were
they've been doing that for thousands of
years yeah uh yeah so
yeah they're saying there's some [ __ ]
going on in our street yeah
look man [ __ ] everybody knows that
china's a problem
but we've always had a problem russia
used to be a problem
everything's temporary it's it's not a
problem that we can't overcome
in time that's what i think you know
what i mean
uh china china's really [ __ ] up
australia
but i don't think that'll last for long
yeah well like i said everything's
temporary
even bad [ __ ] they'll fit yeah we'll
figure it out yeah
we'll get through this it's okay
everybody yeah hope so
um i hope so all right so keep your chin
up
yeah we'll just you know well so anyway
i guess we'll wrap it up we've been
going on for a long time
um so yeah and on the apocalypse it's a
zombie musical
uh but i'm gonna watch another christmas
movie tonight another christmas horror
movie and like i said i may or may not
be reviewing it by myself you might be
back by then so we'll see how it goes
um and or it might be a little bit later
i'll let you guys know what's going on
all right so uh we'll see you guys again
tomorrow and thanks for dropping by
everybody
bye